all right so today blessing got beat by
Anthony and I so I challenged blessing
to going up and down the stairs and
blessing was supposed to do it right but
he got scared I mean he had done it
before he had done it before yesterday I
thought about life so now we have
Michael we're gonna do a race to see who
can go down 21 flights upstairs and up
21 flights of stairs faster now me on
the semi-pro athlete
you already know listen I don't even
need to say that just look at me baby
you know what it is look at me yeah
there you go there you go
yeah today afternoon
a lot yeah no food yeah but let's do
this no excuses
I said
thank you
I wasn't expecting you guys
he went too fast he died
I got to 17 and I quit I was like
I can't even breathe I just did you
compare with this challenge I don't want
bro I don't know why I don't know I
don't mind bro
how did two guys do we live in this
competitions
embarrassing so I guess I'm gonna put on
myself let's go to this one yeah
whatever
I didn't even
think no you know what when I've got to
15 up on the news